thank you for inviting me today I'm
Murray west and I'm director of the
British universities film and video
Council which is an organization and
central organization in the UK which is
doing some of this sort of work to
deliver content to universities in
particular for learning teaching and for
research we're there I just give a bit
of background to who we are we promote
the production the study in the use of
moving image and sound in UK higher
education and research now most of our
resource is focused on the United
Kingdom some of the things we do are
made widely available and i'll show you
some of those things in a moment we've
set up in 1948 so we weren't just set up
a few years ago and we were in the
british film institute from 1968 onwards
and left in 1982 and we have our own
life now under the UK higher education
funding councils we're funded with core
funding we're a company limited company
charity status so we trade and we earn
money as a nonprofit organization which
we put back into the core and we receive
about a million dollars a year at the
cords about 500,000 pounds a year on the
current exchange rate
oh and we have subscribing members the
way it works is we provide value to all
universities united kingdom in fact
anyone who wants to get into our website
but the particular things which need to
be sustained have to be paid for and
there's a subscription from universities
that join so as around 230 institutions
all joined there's about 200
institutions which you could call
university standing in UK and we have
many of them in but not all in
membership and they get various services
and so on and but as I say some of our
stuff goes out widely online and we
undertake not only sort of service
development but research and project
development as well that's the front
page of our website and I'm going to
gallop through now because I feel I've
got far too much to try to pass on to
you and I apologize if I do sort of
ramble but I'm going to try to get
through as fast as I can I'll try to
take you through some of the reasons why
I think moving pictures are used at all
in education which sounds rather so
bring us down a little bit because
really I'm a service provider and we
want to have an effect with the work we
do so the question is what what I'm
moving images used for in education and
I think all of this stuff is fairly
elderly there's the instrumental use of
course that's illustration the audio
visual aid and what a burden that has
been to us in many ways as well as the
burden of having entertainment take
moving pictures away from scientists who
first invented them in effect because i
think this legacy is has held us up
somewhat in getting the content into the
scholarly world as enrichment as a word
it's used regularly but let's say
working in the affective domain let's
talk about Bloom's taxonomy maybe for a
moment because there are different ways
people learn changing hearts and minds
learning things the cognitive or
learning how to do things the
psychomotor think these are quite
important ideas which quite elderly
human behavior but terribly important to
us and then and I might say we're right
in the heart of this as primary resource
a primary record or secondary record
capable of use and to be continuously
referral long term to rely on it being
there as standard content to look back
at to write about to review and to
engage with on a continuous basis and
then as a scientific device the
scientists we had a book this came out
recently it's an old book just recently
reported as Italian rich and written by
virgilio tozi its canal called cinema
before cinema of course science invented
moving pictures then the Lumiere
brothers and one or two other fair
ground and fit up merchants came along
and made it entertainment and arguably
there's still a lot to be said about
moving image as a fundamental research
tool and then as live communication of
course now see a lecture drop into a
conference talk to your peers online and
as a creative medium now it's fairly
sort of basic analysis but right now I'm
going to look at some of those things
which we do which tend to focus on the
things which are in red here rather than
those other things here that's today
anyway we're interested in all of these
now that moving pitches their status in
scholarship i might say 30-something
years ago and i started in this field i
thought it was a done deal and mike it's
still isn't and it's disheartening
really i told you we organization
started 1948 and i look back to the
journal articles written in 1949 1950 we
probably be reading them now just change
one or two words and be the same
messages and we haven't got very far
we've had just about a hundred years of
recorded moving pictures but unlike text
in the united kingdom and i don't know
enough about the youth the u.s. we have
no statutory deposit we have no unified
national catalog we've got poor research
access in fact almost non-existent
research access we've got no
interlibrary loan which standard in the
UK for a book you go the smallest light
in the UK an order book and three or
four weeks later will come from
somewhere on the library network we've
got no arrangements for fair dealing you
call it fair use over here this is all
changing because we have just reviewed
this because fair dealing broadcasting
and film is not including our fair
dealing arrangements yet we've got no
developed culture of reference or review
from the scholarly perspective in my
view there's a times literary supplement
but we haven't got a times moving image
supplement it's just indicative of where
we are we've righted the backwards and
there's very rare integration of this
content with text sources and there is
poor or non-existent teacher training
for use in the United Kingdom all sorts
of things are talk to teachers about
teaching but very little about
engagement with moving image content and
what you can expect to find and how to
find it and all those sorts of things so
we've got a huge uphill struggle still I
want to show you a bit of movie just to
break things up a bit I think the public
is more likely to be concerned at the
extraordinarily intemperate language
which is coming out on behalf of the
Prime Minister in your name the story
was a lie it is a lie correct weasel
words weasel not instantly spelt
correctly inconsistent terms with the
original well if I may say so the
statement that you're reading from was
read to the Press Association so that I
wouldn't get hung up on a spelling
mistake by somebody's time too although
know that you and you also John reported
the four people in my office were
responsible to writing the so-called
dodgy dossier when they were not however
put that to one side the reason that is
weasel words is it does not answer the
questions that i put i asked the BBC
whether they were standing by the
allegation they made the BBC made as
John Humphries described it the BBC made
the allegation that we deliberately
exaggerated a beer the answers of not to
question the BBC question the answer to
the question you put to the BBC do they
stand by it the answer is yes the answer
a robust yes excuse me that letter
is about as robust as blackburn rovers
war when they played trelleborg now I
don't know whether you saw this in the
US you may well have done because it was
reference to the build-up to the Iraq
war the question is though what was that
recording when was it recorded and by
who why was it recorded what were they
talking about what is the dodgy dossier
who were the people in it how and when
was a recording released how many people
saw it is there any other related
content is this sequence likely to have
long-term value and how can I get a hold
of it and what can I do well that came
from ITN and in fact we had a group of
12 people at that time working in there
at that moment when it happened some of
you'll be able to answer some of those
questions that some of you want many of
you will not know who that guy was
exactly what he was talking about and
that my point about this is metadata is
king the promise the the origin of this
content and so on it is so important if
we strip this away if we harvest the
stuff in such a way that you do not know
what this means we're in deep trouble
and I think the people from google and
other places that seem to be making so
much money realize that metadata me much
more than the contents being delivered
it's a bit like farming I said this the
other day you know farmers prices are
going down and down and down and yet
somehow other supermarkets are making
more money certainly the United Kingdom
how can that be the producers are not
you know the content somehow doesn't get
monetized in quite the same way as the
metadata at the moment the middleman but
what do most teachers and students want
and this is a fairly primitive
explanation but I hope it's gone into
most of the nooks and crannies high
quality finding systems and problems
detailed links simple and elegant access
to arrangements to the content maximum
flexibility and licensing for reused
long term access in perpetuity perhaps
opportunities for exchange and use
locally and licensed for public
demonstration
their work now I said earlier that we
have to find ways to sustain the work we
do and philosophically I'm very keen on
open access and open content at the same
time we have to find a way to get the
funds in to do the work and to sustain
it and so with very much
subscription-based at the moment and we
use authenticated access for UK students
with the greatest flexibility we hope
for access to the content we deal with
now news from online is a big thing
we're just finishing and I'm going to
have to now speed up because I can see
the clock is ticking away we have just
come out of their offices and I think
it's one of the greatest collaborations
for a long time between academia and a
full-on commercial television company
3,000 hours of content in three file
formats that's 65,000 segments around 10
million thumbnails that derived from the
movies you can get very nice still
pictures a lot of movies as you encode
them which are quite valuable and we
hope to release this or at least JYSK
the joint information systems committee
which gives us quite a lot of money
hopes to deliver that within six months
now some of that stuff can be seen
online already in a placeholder website
which you can actually play with from
anywhere in the world and download the
content and the key to this is we don't
do streaming we do download so you get a
copy to play with as I've been playing
with that one of other stuff plant
workers name of the guy and Jon Snow
doing the interviewing ITN let us have
full run of error code basically we came
with about two million pounds of
government money and we've come away
with 3,000 hours it works out around 600
pounds an hour in fact previous work
we've done as 600 pounds an hour to get
it ready do the metadata encourage get
it ready to go up and that's our sort of
benchmark at the moment with good
quality catalogers and on this site you
can search and we can then and this is
one which you could go and play with
yourself later on this is one I've just
downloaded
a sea of placards by the River Thames
each saying no to war in Iraq marching
through the streets of London sending a
message to tony blair and george w bush
not in my name it's the scale of the
protest that is unprecedented organizers
say two million people though police say
less than half that number it's the
biggest rally ever on British soil made
up of pacifists Christian groups Muslim
organizations and many many labour
supporters the real Tony Blair certainly
wasn't here his father-in-law however
was if you have a message for the
government what would it be give peace a
chance and thousands upon thousands of
ordinary people galvanized into action
many for the first time by the belief
that an invasion of Iraq cannot be
justified servers before all happen and
we've got bundles of stuff now which
will be able to look back at and the
dodgy dossier and everything else and I
think for years and years to come
they'll be analysis going on of what did
happen and who is duping Hugh grew and
so on another thing we've worked on is
now expressing itself as film and sound
on line seven thousand items and these
are about 500 hours of movies and music
collection segmented we segment our
stuff we met you can get the whole movie
we also have a bit behind an
authentication barrier the music sounds
something like this well we down bit of
mind and this is music we've licensed
for bending stretching doing what you
like with
and it is some of the finest stuff to
come out of Abbey Road Studios one of
George Martin's colleagues and we have
the right to do that in perpetuity and
that's been proved to be useful this is
what we call the scratch and sniff
contract as you go into the website at
the bottom they've got to do something
and say yes I agree about all students
and staff in UK universities can have
access to this and it's progressive
download this is the interface we didn't
build and here is an example trials of
algae hiss one of the great movies John
Lowe entails movie we have up it's a
three hour magnum opus documentary some
of you may know and this is the sort of
metadata we put together and you can
scroll down this is the bit about the
segment and you can download in windows
media or whatever standard stuff quick
time and you've got it to use as I'm
trying to right now our licensed by the
way allows me to show it to you today
for promotion and to express what we're
doing I'm afraid probably I won't be
able to sign the bit of docket later for
it to be distributed again but that's
another thing we can talk about under
Creative Commons that is and this is the
piece sorry I've got
its original purpose was the communist
infiltration of the American government
when it was certainly one of its
eventual objective right after chambers
finished his testimony we received a
wire from Alger Hiss asking for the
opportunity to be heard on his side of
the case and so we gave him that chance
just two days like a little exchange
what all the famous thing is and mr. Nix
Nix which is not in the rare but which
nest but his said hi I'm a graduate not
hot busty and I believe yours is
quitting and this just absolutely ripped
mr. Nixon's apart a very big thing which
we've got online and is the biggest
thing in fact I think in the UK it's the
only clothes transmission access route
to records of broadcasts United Kingdom
we decided a few years ago to start
ingesting with a subscription to big
database provider all the television and
radio records for a reception in the
united kingdom as around 350 channels
and it amounts to 1.3 million records a
year up to 7.8 million records so far so
you can roughly work out how long we've
been doing this and under a special
license under UK law we can record any
broadcasts we like pretty much and so
we're recording 44,000 hours a year of
UK television we've been doing that
since 1998 so we've got a huge stock
around three hundred thousand hours of
television maybe a bit more we're doing
seven channels twenty-four seven and
we'd like to do more but you know every
time you add a channel it gets another
incremental cost and this is really
supported by subscription because we're
allowed to provide copies of programs to
students and staff in universities under
licence for use on campus in learning
and teaching
and it is a marvelous better UK law
we've got 22,000 registered users there
it's an authenticated system this and
where you get into it you'd see
something like this it actually receives
the data 10 days in advance of
transmission so we can actually you can
set up your own thing so it tells you
what programs are coming on in any
channel receivable which might be on
volcanoes or whatever you're interested
in I don't know if you know I might be
on George Bush and you set up a little
routine so I'm interested in George Bush
any programs that come in say you know
and it'll send you an email saying
they're coming up on these channels it's
a very elegant thing and it's it's
probably our sort of pointing back
called killer application to help to
assist us in being the 44,000 hours a
year if you do a search you'll find
there's a little pinger here somewhere
as a little identifier automatically the
system will tell you whether we have a
copy and the interesting thing is used
on it I unique identifier number so that
if the same program arrives on another
channel at some point in the future
which we don't record it'll still ping
up to say we got a copy because even
though we didn't record the channel as
you understand what I'm saying and
that's very handy because programs move
around all over the place this was a
search for George Bush I think and then
it was going back six months I don't
know what this is there's some sort of
satirical program about George Bush we
can provide this physically through the
post we're just moving to a licensing
arrangement where we may be able to
provide just throw the switch so people
can go into our hard disk based system
which is ingesting this content it's
like a giant TiVo box so the university
staff can go straight from the database
and say I want a copy of that now it
won't come immediately he'll come in
store them forward it will come during
the night and arrived but i don't think
i can show you this for obvious reasons
we didn't clear the rights in this to
show you and i'd probably breached all
sorts of rights and the big fear is
what's going to happen if
if you have reached right I carry now
five million pounds worth of
professional indemnity insurance that's
10 million dollars at the US current
currency rates paid for by someone else
because the responsibility for these
things delivered into UK universities
risks on my shoulders the UK the
government won't take any responsibility
for anything so if anything goes to the
UK government funded your agencies they
send a letter to me because I've said
yes you can do it there's one way of
handling things I know the rights people
at Lloyds didn't foot onion the API
people at Lloyds didn't fully understand
the use of the insurance in that way but
that's what we're done now we have gone
about clearing rights in the
conventional sense in the way that we
have contracts with owners the ITN
content by the way is in perpetuity it's
progressive download it's all staff and
students of United Kingdom bona fide
staff students of the United Kingdom
whether they are sitting in the UK or
abroad which is useful so they can sit
in Hong Kong as long as they are
registered with the UK University and
now the ITN has told you if you see that
we may be able to issue a license to us
universities if we would like to discuss
it so we'd like to find another
organization or like view if you see we
could talk to I don't we could easily
talk to all the universities but it
would be nice to see the central
organization which might help us to do
that um I think rights clearance you got
to stare the monster in the face and
you've got it you've got to go for these
things and I think we're making headway
and I think what's happened now there is
greater collaboration with owners
whatever people say there is something
giving in the system when we first went
to 80 and then when in two thousand
pounds a minute for digitization rights
this was in 1994 and the whole process
has not matured myself by then you know
it's all change we paid a hundred pounds
an hour for the rights component for the
ITN content in perpetuity so it's a
tokenistic payment really I'd only had
some breaching any
of confidentiality is at all um I think
it's a growing understanding of
education needs and indeed the chief
executive officer at the time Stewart
Purvis of itmn reuters/reuters
television was and he said look this is
my career as much as anything else that
you're going to be putting down and I'd
like to see that happen and I think
they're sort of on our side and I think
we need the dialogue um we've got this
formal review which is just going on in
you know dick in Tuba call it the
gaolers review which is actually
extending exceptions but getting very
hard with remedies if you breach thing
so it's interesting that things are
softening up in one way but getting
harder and another and I think this is
not a bad thing um and there are going
to be new licensing arrangements to be
offered within copyright exceptions
that's that when you break the monopoly
of copyright which we can do under the
Berne Convention in certain cases and
the sharing licenses like Creative
Commons yet fair enough I needed it
right and I know Paul would be like to
talk about that in the moment they're
coming forward I see this is a patchwork
quilt of delivery I'm not bothered that
there's youtube there really because I
think there are free handouts free
newsletters free all sorts of things
around and then there's the high quality
high value stuff which you may have to
pay a small amount for somewhere with
some license right at top level which is
priya the point of use think we
and now right bye-bye high-quality i
meant high quality metadata and all the
rest of it i mean that the fact is the
thing is structured content is
structured so you can find it and get
the provenance and and all that stuff
and that sort of thing I mean people put
print on notice boards they put printed
parish newsletters they they you know
agitprop has been around a long time I
think you know it's the fact is what
we're trying to do is to build a corpus
of scholarly engagement with this type
of content I hope which stands slightly
differently from that which is all over
the place okay but i do think
international harmonization is something
we're all going for and all of these
things and I think g8 is probably trying
to do that because I think there's been
a review here of exceptions in sign and
I think we do need greater communication
with rights owners rather than less
though it's important because they will
come on board if we talk in the right
talk at the right times
you